let's read some more about last we've
got this article here
it is from what what organ is this from
I don't see it here what was this from
The Washington Post Professor Sean found
this one oh it's called against
decluttering our obsession with purging
is bad for the planet and making us
ashamed of our homes
shame on utk for making people feel
ashamed of their homes home shamer
all right this is written by Brit
Peterson we'll put a link to this in the
show notes Alabama take it away
I'm writing this at a desk littered with
objects
ceramic chicken
for me in Brazil multiple expired gift
cards and a framed photo of my partner
and me in college looking rudely young
there's an old Christmas tree shaped
Christmas ornament and an Easter Bunny
shaped Easter egg basket a vintage
postcard of the flat iron building on
the back someone in 1908 wrote hello Ada
no doubt you've forgotten about me by
this time but I assure you that I still
remember you and two boxes of picture
hangers it's half junk and half treasure
but I've gotten so used to the mix that
I haven't thrown anything out in years
and I've found that I prefer it that way
through years of excitable media
coverage we've convinced ourselves that
decluttering can solve all kinds of
problems from bad sleep to poor mental
health to relationship conflict recently
however there's been a backlash from
environmentalists feminists design
maximalists and Book Lovers it's
understandable we would cling to
decluttering a practice with deep
spiritual and historic Roots but there
may be other ways to interact with our
belongings that would spark a more
lasting joy and be better for the planet
and the humans around us as well let's
pause right there so TK
I actually agree with this all author if
we are shaming people for having clutter
that is a terrible way and I hope that
it never comes off at least we don't
come off as shaming other people for
their possessions I don't judge people I
merely identify I was exactly where you
were if you're listening to this podcast
you made it this far is that clock right
are we really over two hours into the
episode wow if you're especially this
far into the podcast you know that there
is a problem with clutter in your life
however there are some people and she
mentions here in this really well
written article she mentions the design
maximalists
and we did a patreon episode let's put a
link to this in the show notes as well
Professor Sean uh about maximalism and
some of my favorite designers are
actually maximalist and I would even say
my favorite literary influence David
Foster Wallace is a literary maximalist
the way that he writes and so I think it
can be profoundly interesting maximalism
and and accumulation of things
intentionally right and the same way
that removing things intentionally is
profoundly interesting the problem we
get into is when we cling to things or
bring on things unintentionally we hoard
that's not intentionalism or if we're
just constantly being a spartanist and
we're jettisoning everything we're
clinging to decluttering as she says
well guess what that's a problem as well
that is also not intentional we'll say
you TK Coleman yeah so I'll point out
one thing that I disagree with here in
the description that actually unites us
the author writes it's half junk and
half treasure that's the phrase that's
used to describe all of these
possessions that are being observed in
the home
and then at the completion of that
sentence says I haven't thrown anything
out in years and I found that I prefer
it that way
and I would say the fact that you prefer
it that way is what takes it from being
half junk and half treasure to being 100
treasure the definition of junk or the
understanding of junk that's being
employed here is
something that I can't justify to
someone else something that I can't
prove to other people that I have a good
reason for keeping around something that
other people would look at and say well
that's useless but none of that matters
when it comes to clutter as it pertains
to minimalism clutter is whatever gets
in the way of what you want to feel and
of how you want to live and if something
is valuable to you it is treasure even
if other people say but you can't
justify it it makes no sense that's
outdated it's expired it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter if it's an old soda
can if sitting that old soda can on your
shelf makes you happy that's not junk to
you and this by the way is true of all
art there isn't a single piece of art
that will ever exist for which someone
can't point to it and say
that's trash art is always trash to
someone else but is it beautiful to you
and so decluttering isn't about forcing
ourselves to purge our homes of things
that we can't justify to society or
things that don't improve our careers
it's about purging our homes of the
things that we believe are junk not for
the sake of escaping Society shame but
for the Escape but for the sake of
getting out of the misery that this is
causing in our lives based on the joy
that we want to feel that's spot on and
that's why with the we have the No Junk
rule we add a third category because
it's not binary it's either treasure or
it's junk or maybe there's this other
categories Treasures like oh this is
essential I I have to have it's a
treasure for me right and then junk it
must be trash which by the way we
pathologize trash as well trash isn't
inherently a bad thing right and so it's
not even bad that it's trash it just
means it's no longer serving you but of
course one person's trash is another
person's treasure but there's this
middle category and these are the things
that are non-essential but value-adding
and that's really what I when I read
this article here what she's talking
about Brent many of the things you own
it's not treasure
half treasure half junk it's half
essential
half non-essential but it adds value to
your life so it's not clutter there's
nothing for you to declutter if it's not
getting in your way
you declutter because these things are
getting in your way and if you handed me
all of your things yes I'm going to
declutter them because they get in my
way but if you enjoy having a messy work
working space great if you're a object
maximalist like my favorite interior
designer is Axel vovort and I have a few
of his books at home and he is a
materialist and the true sense of the
word he looks in the material object and
says wow this is special this is Art and
he's a curator of objects he doesn't
Heap on a bunch of objects ceaselessly
into his life and grab this and grab
this hold on to this cling to this that
is beautiful
and I don't want to possess it I want
the object to possess me to to give me
that Spirit of intentionality with
everything I bring into my home whether
it's one object or 1 000 objects they
might be non-essential but if they're
adding value to your life
why get rid of them yeah preference
passion and priority it's the Midas
touch that transforms everything it
comes into contact with into gold if you
have something in your home that Society
labels as clutter the moment you say I
prefer it I'm passionate about it I
choose to prioritize that thing it
ceases to be cluttered in that instance
I think about uh in the World of Magic
Abracadabra is phrase that means I
create as I speak when you look at
something in your home even if it
previously was junk even if it's
something that's been left behind by
someone else when you look at that thing
and you say you know what
I really like this here it brings me joy
that's an Abra cadabra that transforms
that thing alchemizes it and makes it
something that is beautiful to you even
if the rest of the world treats it as
junk Tick Tock that Danny unknown I
gotta say one other thing for this it
does become clutter in one other
instance if it harms you or it harms
someone else even if you like it but it
is harming you or especially harming
someone else then you can recognize it
as clutter I'm thinking about my
daughter has a friend who she really
likes and uh she was going over her
house because she has a this was my
first red flag she has a bunch of cats
and I'm like how many cash I got like 20
. oh
okay huge red flag but okay I'll let you
go over there I have some mistake on my
part and I should have done a better job
vetting and I generally do a really good
job of vetting I didn't in this one
instance because uh the mothers seemed
totally fine but I didn't so I got a
good first impression but the first
impression is not everything
and eventually I go to pick her up that
night from her friend's house and I show
up and the first thing
she says to me the mother says to me is
and she doesn't know that I'm one of the
minimalist at least I don't think she
does she's never mentioned it she goes
oh I'm sorry about the mess I've been
purging all day I'm trying to get rid of
and I knew right away like this was a
story that she tells herself all the
time she's telling herself I should get
rid of these things but she's also
telling herself a conflicting story I
can't get rid of these things when I
showed up it was like walking into a
horror film
I parked the car and literally with
every step that I took things got worse
I saw the chicken coops to one side and
she doesn't live in the middle of
nowhere it's it's fine have some chicken
coops whatever then I see a goat
standing on a table
inside of a cage
and then I keep walking and there's like
a bunch of patio furniture and I say a
bunch I mean like seven houses worth of
patio furniture piled onto their patio
in various ways it's completely unusable
it's an rendered useless by the way that
it is piled up together and I get to the
front door and at least four dogs greet
me at the front door
and it just gets worse and worse from
there there are cats I can tell you for
sure there's got to be some sort of
problem with insect infestations and
other things like this is a true level
four level five hoarder somewhere in in
there it's not a judgment of that person
but it's a judgment of my daughter's
safety and recognizing oh you can't be
in this environment you're still allowed
to have this friend
but I should have never let you go into
this environment and thank God she's
okay
[Music]
um
I
it was a mistake on my part to let her
go into an environment like that but the
less I learned from that is while she is
okay there I needed a better job vetting
it doesn't mean I need to I don't need
to pad her entire I don't need to bubble
wrap her world right I don't go to the
playground she's gonna go play on the
the the little spinny wheel and put
bubble wrap all over that so I don't
want you to hurt yourself but also I
don't want her to get into an
environment where that is okay because
that has a potential to be harmful to
her and of course harmful to the people
around her and that is when decluttering
and it goes Way Beyond just getting rid
of the stuff this hoarding is a is a
mental illness it's on the OCD spectrum
and that level of hoarding specifically
stage four stage five hoarding is when
it becomes harmful to the people around
us I hope you enjoyed that highlight
from the minimalist private podcast if
you'd like another highlight check out
this video if you'd like to watch the
minimal episode check out this video or
if you'd like to dive deep into full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast head on over to patreon the link
is in the description your support keeps
our podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free